- A few months ago.
I made a video about a
difficult Turkish exam question,
and that video seemed to
resonate with a lot of people.
There were comments in Turkish
that were glad that
people could see the pain
that they had to go through,
and there were plenty of
comments lamenting the state
of the education system.
Let me show you some of the comments
that gained a lot of support.
This one translates to
you only have a black pen
but create a rainbow.
This is a summary of the
Turkish education system.
And this one says that the
questions are of high quality,
but unfortunately, there is no system
that will take us to the
answers of those questions.
Now, I have never studied in Turkey
and I don't know enough
to agree or disagree
with these statements
but they do relate to a larger sentiment
that we see in many other countries.
And that is that the exam
is not the challenge,
the real challenge is competing
against the other students.
The exam in question is the AYT paper
used to gain entrance
into Turkish universities.
The population of Turkey is 85 million
and over two million students
are taking this test,
hoping to be in the top 50,000
to get into the good universities.
When entry is so competitive,
you see exams getting harder
to try and separate people.
But many are left feeling frustrated
by the fact that making exams harder
doesn't raise the quality of education
and instead can leave
students feeling dejected
and hating school.
This comment said geography is destiny.
And this one said may God help Turkish,
Indian and South Korean students,
assumably talking about the
tough exams they all have.
Another common thread
was people saying that
even if you're lucky enough
to ace this exam, get
into a good university
and graduate, that there are
still not many jobs waiting
for you at the end.
This OECD unemployment rate data does show
that Turkey has a pretty
high unemployment rate.
The latest figures are around 11.2%
whilst the USA and the UK are at 4%
and Australia, 4.2%.
It also seems like a lot
of the top students aspire
to go overseas,
contributing to what they call brain drain
where a country's brightest people
aren't sticking around to help it grow.
I planned to work through another one
of the tough questions
from the AYT exam paper
and I will get to doing that in this video
but first, I got distracted
by another comment
that told me to check out the LGS exam
given to middle schoolers in Turkey
as a high school entrance exam.
It is very hard.
A math question this year
was taken from the university exam.
They are literally forcing students
to solve university level
questions at age 13 to 14.
So naturally, I wanted to take a look.
Here's the paper and
yes, it's really hard.
Apparently, students studying for this
are putting in eight plus hour study days,
making it the youngest example
of that kind of hard work
I've seen for an exam yet.
Let's take a look at the last question
on the math section.
We've got these pie charts,
which show the distribution
of televisions sold
in an electronics store in 2019 and 2020.
K, L and M are three different
types of televisions.
It says that while the number
of L brand televisions sold
in this store in 2020 decreased by 25
compared to 2019, the M
brand televisions increased
in number by 40.
According to this,
what is the number of K brand
televisions sold in 2019?
So we wanna know how many televisions
does this slice of pie represent?
That would be easy to do
if, for example, we knew
how many televisions
were sold in total,
either in 2019 or 2020.
But that's not information that we have.
So this becomes quite tricky.
Please do have a go at solving it
and while you're at it,
I would like to quickly thank the sponsor
of this video, Babbel.
I've done a lot of translating
to try and read these exam questions
and the comments,
and I've actually been using Babbel
to learn just the basics
from the Turkish language
to make it easier for me
to pick out keywords.
Babbel is a top language learning app
that teaches real-world
practical conversations
through 10-minute interactive lessons,
as well as podcasts, games, videos
and live classes.
Babbel teaches more than just vocab words
and also teaches you about
the language's culture,
people, history and traditions.
(instructor speaking in foreign language)
(phone beeping)
(narrator speaking in foreign language)
(instructor speaking in foreign language)
(phone beeping)
(narrator speaking in foreign language)
Learning a new language is the perfect way
to work on yourself in 2022,
and Babbel is offering a
20-day money-back guarantee.
You can get 65% off
by going to my link, which
is down in the description.
(instructor speaking in foreign language)
And now let's take a look at the solution.
So there might be a number of ways
to solve it but the simplest way I found
was to try and find out
how many TVs each degree
of the pie represents.
I'm going to define this variable X,
which is how many TVs there are
in each degree of the pie in 2019.
And also, I'm going to define why,
which is the same thing
but for the 2020 pie chart.
Now let's look at the chart.
We will want to know how many degrees
are in this section K.
At first glance, it might
look like it's 1/3, 120,
like this one down here
but actually, it's not.
If this one here, L, is
90 degrees, M is 120,
and in total, this has to add to 360,
then K will actually be 150 degrees.
Over here it's a bit more simple.
We've got 90, 90 and so this
one would have to be 180.
If we can find x,
then the problem will be solved
by finding 150 times x.
That will be how many TVs
this chunk represents.
If that's 150x,
then this one here is 90x, 120x.
Since the number of M
brand televisions increases
in number by 40,
then this section here
will be 120x plus 40.
And since L decreases in number by 25,
this one here will be 90x minus 25.
And these segments can also
be represented using y.
This one is also 90 degrees times y
and this one down here is 180y.
And since these represent the same number
of TVs in this chunk,
we can write 90x minus 25
is equal to 90y.
And for this one,
120x plus 40 is equal to 180y.
This is our key to solving the problem.
We've got two unknowns
but also two equations,
so we can solve this for both x and y.
Rearranging the top one for y
and subbing that into the second one,
I get x to be 3/2.
Remember what we wanted to
solve the problem was 150x.
So 150 times 3/2.
Well, that is 450/2,
which is equal to 225,
meaning that C is the correct answer.
Now, it took me a few goes to get there
but if you found this
easily, then congratulations,
you're as smart as a Turkish 13-year-old.
I can't help but think
that if you already are studying so hard
for exams this early
that by the time you get
to those tougher
university entrance exams,
you may have already burned out.
But it seems like even getting into some
of the best high schools
is a competitive process.
This is a question
from that notorious
university entrance exam.
This is from the 2021
AYT mathematics paper.
Translated, it says that P of x
is a fourth degree polynomial
with real coefficients.
And it gives the inequality that P of x
is bigger than or equal to x.
It gives us three values of P of x
at x is one, two and three.
And it asks us to find the value of P of x
at x is equal to four.
Now, on an axes of x and P of x,
this line here represents
where P of x is equal to x.
Our function is called P of x
but it could just as
easily have been called y
and you may recognize this
as more commonly called
the line y equals x.
This inequality tells us
that the value of our function
will always exist above or at this line.
So in this region here.
In fact, we can plot some of the points.
At x is equal to one,
P of x is also equal to one,
so that point is on the line.
The same thing happens
at x is equal to three.
In between that x is equal to two,
the value of P of x is four.
So it will be somewhere up here.
And since we know it's a
fourth degree polynomial
or a quartic, we know it'll
be a wibbly wobbly shape.
But because it can't pass down
into this region down here,
it must look something like this.
And our question wants
us to find the value
when x is equal to four.
So when it's somewhere up here,
finding the value of this polynomial
at any x value would be easy
if only we had the equation of this line.
But the equation of this line
is slightly hard to find
when we look at it on this perspective.
Instead, let's take a
look at our inequality.
If we subtract x from both sides,
we have that P of x minus x
is bigger than or equal to zero.
Subtracting x off this function
makes it something that's
easier to find an equation for
because it will intersect the x-axis.
Plotting P of x minus x,
we get something that
looks more like this.
And you can see where I've
got these points from.
I just subtracted x
from these values here.
One minus one would give
us a value of zero there.
Four minus two gives
the coordinate two, two
and three minus three gives
the coordinate three, zero.
I know the x-intercepts of this quartic,
so I can actually write its equation.
I'd get K, which is some scale factor
that we're yet to find.
X minus one squared
times x minus three squared.
If you're slightly
unfamiliar with quartics,
you may wonder how I know
that these are both squared.
Well, I can tell what
they call the multiplicity
of the zeros by actually
looking at the graph.
Also called the order, the multiplicity
is how many zeros are at the x-intercept.
For example, if the multiplicity was one,
that would be if this
bracket wasn't squared.
It was just a single value of x.
In that case, the x-intercept
would be cut in a linear fashion.
The intercept would
look something like this
or like this.
With a multiplicity of two,
that's when we would see an x squared
and the intercept would
look like a quadratic,
something like this or this.
This is for a multiplicity of two
but also four, six, eight
and in fact any even number.
And a multiplicity of three
or of five, seven, nine
and any other odd number,
we would see something
that looks like this
where the intercept is in there.
Fun fact is the higher this
number of multiplicity,
the flatter this section will look.
Our x-intercepts come down and turn around
in that sort of quadratic function,
so that's why we can say
that that would be squared.
If we're dealing with a quartic,
that is a power of x to the four,
then the total
multiplicities added together
will equal four.
We do still want to find the value of K
and we can do that
using these points here.
If we used x equals one,
we'd end up with one minus one is zero.
That would all be zero
and it wouldn't be useful for finding K.
Same thing would happen if we used three.
That's probably why they've
given us this one in between.
If P of two minus two is equal to two,
we'd have K, two minus one is one squared,
two minus three is -1 squared.
That would all be one
and K would just be equal to two.
So this would be our final equation
for P of x minus x
and that's all we need
to be able to find P of four.
Plugging in x is equal to four,
it works out to give us the answer of 22.
Luckily, that's one of our options
and so we can say that
B is the right answer.
I know that in the real exam,
you get a lot less time
than I've taken here
but I'm trying to explain things as I go,
especially if this problem is
an unfamiliar type for you.
What makes the exam even harder
is that this might be
an unfamiliar question
to almost everyone.
It doesn't look like it
appears in last year's exam
and so there's not really any warning
to prepare for something like this.
Interestingly, this exam made
the news in Turkey this week
after a decision from the
Council of Higher Education
to change the minimum passing score.
Whilst entry to the top universities
will remain very competitive,
students could still be placed
in a less competitive program
after getting as little
as one question correct.
In Turkey, there are many
higher education institutes
but they're not all of the same quality.
Perhaps this decision could lead
to more low-quality institutes
offering degrees that don't help
to reduce the country's unemployment
or we'll see private
universities now accepting anyone
who's willing to pay the tuition fee.
Thanks for watching this video
and again, let me know your
thoughts down in the comments.
This video is in honor
of today's Patron Cat of the Day, Latte
sent in by Connor.
(tranquil music)